hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're talking about
endospores in now biologists can use a
variety of differential stains to
distinguish between and identify
different types of bacteria using a
light microscope these include Gram
stain and acid fasting both of which are
very popular stains if you're interested
in learning more about them see my
videos on those two stains another type
of stain is the spore stain and there
are a couple of different methods for
staining endospores remember the end of
spores are tough dormant non
reproductive structures that certain
types of gram positive bacteria form
during harsh environmental condition if
you're interested in learning more about
endospores
or the process of forming endospores
called correlation see my videos on
those topics now
the spore stains both start the same way
with heat fixing a sample to a slide
this is when you placed the sample on a
microscope slide and then you just pass
the microscope slide through a Bunsen
burner flame
this helps the bacteria and a sample to
adhere to the slide so they don't get
washed off during later stains the next
step is to add caramel houston this is a
red dye
and at this point the car will keep sin
will stain everything in the sample so
endospores
vegetative cells everything the next
step is very important for getting the
stain to actually stick with the end of
scores remember that the spore coat is
very tough it's very improving as to
chemicals and so in order to make that
stain actually stick to the end of score
you have to do one of two things you can
either steam this like this means
leaving the slide over a source of steam
like a hot water bath for 3 to 5 min if
you don't want to do that you can also
use some kind of surfactant or
detergents this will disrupt the spore
coat enough to allow the stain to a hear
although it certainly won't kill the in
this nor next you rinse with acid
alcohol the acid alcohol will cause the
stain to leave the vegetative cells but
still adhere to the and avoid
so at this point the endospores can be
visualized under a microscope however it
is a good idea to use methylene blue as
a counterstain this means that the
second guy won't cover up the carbonyl
Houston red guide paint the endospores
but it will stain the other vegetative
sets
and of course the endospores will still
be ready so with the same like this you
can see red endospores
you can see blue vegetative bacteria you
can even see bacteria that are in the
process of forming in those books so
that is the molar score stain the Shafer
Fulton's fourth day is very very similar
it just exchanges some things for others
for example and the Schaefer Fulton
happen instead of using carbon fussen
you use malachite green which change the
endospores green as a counter stain you
can use safranin instead of methylene
blue crapper and we'll say all of the
vegetative cells pink so it's just a
different way of visualizing in this
course so that is it for this video on
endospore stain I hope you learned a lot
and thanks for watching